well warner brothers executives must be
really happy right now so uh the most
recent video that i put out on the main
channel was one talking about everything
going on at warner brothers discovery
dealing with a lot of stuff but ending
on what the current status of the flash
is and i mentioned at that point that
the executives at warner brothers
discovery were considering three options
and if you want to know more about the
other options you can check out that
video but the option that they obviously
wanted to happen the most appears to now
be happening ezra miller through their
representation has issued an apology and
has stated that they are now seeking
treatment for quote-unquote complex
mental health issues
so this is pretty much best case
scenario for warner brothers because so
long as they don't relapse and go right
back to the same behavior they were
doing before the film releases it's just
gonna come out
honestly it was probably gonna come out
regardless but now it'll come out with
warner brothers executives breathing
much more easily
and maybe fans will too i don't know do
people still care